when I was a teen I had terrible periods
I had crippling cramps high leaked blood
onto my clothes and onto my bedsheets
and I had period diarrhea and I had to
miss school one to two days a month and
I remember sitting on the couch with my
heating pad thinking what's up with this
when I ate food I didn't leak saliva
from my salivary glands when I went for
a walk I didn't leak fluid from my knees
joint fluid
why was menstruation so different I
wanted answers to these questions but
there was no one for me to ask my mother
knew nothing about menstruation except
that it was dirty and shameful and I
shouldn't talk about it
I asked girlfriends and everybody spoke
in euphemisms and finally when I got the
courage to go to the doctor and talk
about my heavy periods I was told to eat
liver and when I went to the drugstore
to buy my menstrual products my 48 pack
of super maxi pads
back in the day when they were the size
of a tissue box each pad you know what
I'm talking about you have no idea how
far absorbent technology has come
I used to have to buy my menstrual
products in the feminine hygiene aisle
and I remember standing there thinking
well why don't I buy toilet paper in the
anal hygiene aisle like what's up with
that why can't we talk about periods and
it's not about the blood as Freud would
have you say because if it were there'd
be an ear nose and throat surgeon up
here right now talking about that taboos
of nosebleeds right and it's not even
about periods because otherwise when we
got rid of our toxic shameful periods
when we became menopausal we'd be
elevated to a higher social status it's
just a patriarchal societies invested in
oppressing women and at different points
in our lives different things are used
and menstruation is used during what we
in medicine called the reproductive
years it's been around since pretty much
the beginning of time many cultures
thought that women could spoil crops or
milk or wilt flowers and then when
religion came along purity myths only
made that worse and medicine wasn't any
health in the 1920s and 30s there was
the idea that women elaborated something
called a minnow toxin we could willed
flowers just by walking by and that's
what happens when there's no diversity
right because there's no woman to put
her hand up and go well actually that
doesn't happen and when you can't talk
about what's happening to your body how
do you break these myths because you
don't even need to be a doctor to say
that periods aren't toxic if they were
why would an embryo implant in a toxic
swill and if we all had this secret
meadow toxin we could be laying waste to
crops and spoiling milk why would we
have not used our ex women powers to get
the vote sooner
even now when I tweet about period
diarrhea as one does I mentioned that it
affects 28% of women and every single
time someone approaches me and says I
thought I was the only one that's how
effective that culture of shame is that
women can't even share their experiences
so I began to think well what if
everybody knew about periods like a
gynecologist wouldn't that be great then
you would all know what I know you'd
know that menstruation is a pretty
unique phenomenon among mammals most
mammals had estrus humans some primates
some bats the elephant shrew in the
spiny Mouse meant straight and with
menstruation what happens is the brain
triggers the ovary to start producing an
egg estrogen is released and it starts
to build up the lining of the uterus
cell upon cell like bricks and what
happens if you build a brick wall too
high without mortar well it's unstable
so what happens when you ovulate you
release a hormone called progesterone
which is pro gestational it gets the
uterus ready it acts like a mortar and
it holds those bricks together it also
causes some changes to make the lining
more hospitable for implantation if
there's no pregnancy lining comes out
there's bleeding for the blood vessels
and that's the period and I always fight
this point really interesting because
with estrus the final signaling to get
the lining of the uterus ready actually
comes from the embryo but with
menstruation that choice comes from the
ovary it's as if choice is coded in to
our reproductive tract
okay so so now we know why the blood is
there and that's a pretty significant
amount it's 30 to 90 milliliters of
blood which is 1 to 3 ounces and it can
be more and I know it seems like it's
more a lot of the times I know so why do
we have so much blood well and white why
doesn't it just stay there until the
next cycle right like you didn't get
pregnant so I can't hang around well
imagine if each month it got thicker and
thicker and thicker right like imagine
what tsunami period that would be we
can't reabsorb it because it's too much
and it's too much because we need a
thick uterine lining for a very specific
reason
pregnancy exerts a significant
biological toll on our bodies there is
maternal mortality there is the toll of
breastfeeding and there is the toll of
raising a child until it is independent
an evolution that goes on longer for
some of us than others but evolution
knows about risk benefit ratio and so
evolution wants to maximize the chance
of a beneficial outcome and how do you
maximize the chance of a beneficial
outcome you try to get the highest
quality embryos and how do you get the
highest quality embryos you make them
work for it
you give them an obstacle course so over
the millennia that we have evolved it's
been a little bit like an arms race in
the uterus the line and getting thicker
and thicker and thicker and the embryo
getting more invasive until we reach
this day taunt with the lining of the
uterus that we have so we have this
thick uterine lining and now it's got to
come out and how do you stop bleeding
well you stop a nosebleed by pinching it
if you cut your leg you put pressure on
it
we stop bleeding with pressure when we
menstruate the lining of the uterus
releases substances that are made into
chemicals called prostaglandins and
other inflammatory mediators and they
make the uterus cramp down they make it
squeeze on those blood vessels to stop
the bleeding
they might also change blood flow to the
uterus and also cause inflammation and
that makes pain worse and so you say ok
well how much pressure is generated
and from studies where some incredible
women have volunteered to have pressure
catheters put in their uterus that they
where their whole menstrual cycle god
bless them because we wouldn't have this
knowledge without and it's very
important knowledge because the pressure
that's generated in the uterus during
menstruation is 120 millimeters of
mercury well what's that you say well
it's the amount of pressure that's
generated during the second stage of
labor when you're pushing right wish and
for those of you who haven't had an
unmedicated delivery that's what it's
like when the blood pressure cuff is not
quite as tight as it was at the
beginning but it's still pretty tight
and you wish it would stop so that kind
of makes it different right if your
start thinking about the pain of
menstruation we wouldn't say if someone
needed to miss school because they were
in the second stage of labor and pushing
we wouldn't call them week we'd be like
oh my god you made it that far right and
we wouldn't deny pain control to women
who have typical pain of labor right so
it's important for us to call this pain
typical instead of normal because when
we say it's normal it's easier to
dismiss as opposed to saying it's
typical and we should address it and we
do have some ways to address menstrual
pain one way is with something called a
TENS unit which you can wear under your
clothes and it sends an electrical
impulse to the nerves and muscles and no
one really knows how it works but we
think it might be the gait theory of
pain which is counter irritations it's
the same reason why if you hurt yourself
you rub it vibration travels faster to
your brain and then pain does we also
have medications called non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory medications and what
they do is they block the release of
prostaglandins they can reduce menstrual
pain for 80% of women they also reduce
the volume of blood by 30 to 40 percent
and they can help with period diarrhea
and we also have hormonal contraception
which gives us a thinner lining of the
uterus so there's less prostaglandins
produced and with less blood there's
less need for cramping now if those
treatments fail you and it's important
to use that word choice because we never
fail the treatment
the treatment fails us if that treatment
fails you you could be amongst the
people who have a resistance to
non-steroidal anti-inflammatories we
don't quite understand but there are
some complex mechanisms why those
medications just don't work for some
women it's also possible that you could
have another reason for painful periods
you could have a condition called
endometriosis where the lining of the
uterus is growing in the pelvic cavity
causing inflammation and scar tissue and
adhesions and there may be other
mechanisms we don't quite understand yet
because it's a possibility that pain
thresholds could be different due to
very complex biological mechanisms but
we're only going to find that out by
talking about it it shouldn't be an
active feminism to know how your body
works it shouldn't
it shouldn't be an active feminism to
ask for help when you're suffering the
era of menstrual taboos is over the only
curse here is the ability to convince
half the population that the very
biological machinery that perpetuates
the species that gives everything that
we have is somehow dirty or toxic and
I'm not going to stand for it and the
way we break that curse it's knowledge
thank you
[Applause]